[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah well I fell in love while I was
introducing that piece with the the
notion of doing it yeah actual doing it
just the notion of doing yeah and my own
image in that monitor all right for
example I was watching that show The
Bachelor
yeah Bachelor and I was watching The
Bachelor and I was watching it for a
little bit and then I hit the info
button and it said American Horror Story
for men with daughters I was watching
the show chopped you know that cooking
show chopped yes there's one petition
yeah a competition show chopped I was
watching it and then I hit the info
button and it said great chefs make bad
dishes from dumb ingredients in front of
jurors
[Applause]
I don't know I was watching the
Republican debate calling myself having
a good time watch the Republican debate
and then I hit the button it said Donald
Trump and seven guys scared shitless by
the
shades of blue I was watching that new
cop drama shades of blue yeah and then I
was you know watching a little bit and
then I hit the info button and it said
each week a new grieving family learns
their loved ones murder must be solved
by Jennifer Lopez what's in that show
blind spot you've seen no blind spot
about it the lady wakes up and she's
covered in tattoos and they're a clue to
a mystery yeah exactly
okay so I was watching that show blind
spot and then I hit the button and it
said the naked tattooed woman mystery
heats up with this week's two-parter her
ass
[Music]
Dance Moms I was watching Dance Moms
never miss it I was watching Dance Moms
then I hit the button and it said
alternate title moms who are about to
lose custody
I was watching Jane the virgin checking
out the show Jane the virgin yep
watching that show very popular then I
hit the button and it said no spoilers
but let's just say that after tonight's
episode we'll need a new title I'm
watching Brooklyn Hawaii five-o and II
watching y5o and then I hit the button
and it said from the producers of we
forgot to cancel them no one can find
them to cancel hit they're in the
mountain somewhere we don't know chill
man and finally Supergirl I was watching
Supergirl yeah
and then I hit the button and it said
the only hero whose superpower is
helping pervs get better upskirt shots
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]